okay let's get to hatred mail if you
don't remember what hatred mail is it
has been a couple weeks since we had our
last one here's a quick reminder we're
getting to the oranges of this
investigation so god bless the United
States Erica Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right
here is this week's hatred mail as usual
needing no introduction
have you ever don't discuss politics
very wise advice from mr. David Park man
don't stir the pot with your canned
spirits I'm David Parkman I worry so
much about what people think about me
that I suffocate myself with a mask I'm
a beta snowflake sheep it's a shame when
your show has become mates yeah I mean
I'm not I'm having trouble parsing the
grammar a little bit there but this is a
political show so we do discuss politics
I'm have you ever don't discuss politics
may be interpreted most charitably means
do we talk about other things on the
show and certainly we do but it is
primarily a political program by the way
you know that speaking of discussing
politics in the last couple of months
it seems that because of coronavirus now
with the protests with what is
essentially a referendum on Donald Trump
coming up in November more and more
people have been writing to me saying I
feel compelled to talk about politics
with my family even though I don't
usually co-workers even even though I
don't usually my significant others
parents even though I don't usually do
you think that there should be this
taboo around talking about politics and
religion where in many other countries
that is it is much more normal to do
that and I'm going to address that in
detail on the Friday show anybody who
knows how I grew up which is politics is
a central piece of what is discussed at
family gatherings at the dinner table
etc I believe that we need to
the taboo from talking about politics
especially because if we don't talk
about me you know I'm kind of going off
on a tangent from the voicemail caller
but from the hatred mail of here but if
we don't talk about politics and model
that people can have disagreements and
then everything is still okay and then
you just finish your dinner and then you
play a video game or watch a TV show and
everybody can still get along
if we don't model that by taking off the
stigma of discussion of politics and
religion then the model people will have
is the way politics is discussed on
social media which is toxic trash so I
am very much in favor of making
political and religious discussions just
mainstream among work co-workers family
etc in the meantime if you want to fight
hate racism you can use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 to save 40% off of your
membership of choice at join pakman.com